welcome to the presentation on
derivatives i think you're going to find
that this is when math starts to become
a lot more fun than it was uh just a few
uh topics ago well let's get started
with what the derivative is and it
sounds very complicated well
in general if i have a straight line let
me see if i can draw a straight line
properly
if i had a straight line that's not
that's my coordinate axes
which aren't straight
and let's see okay so this is a straight
line
when i have a straight line like that
and i ask you to find the slope i think
you already know how to do this it's
just the change in y divided by the
change of x if i wanted to find
the slope really i mean the slope is the
same because it is a straight line the
slope is the same across the whole line
but if i wanted to say find the
um the slope at any point in this line
what i would do is i would pick a point
x
right
so i'd pick at this point we'd pick a
different color
i take this point
and pick this point
it's pretty arbitrary i could pick any
two points and i would figure out what
the change in y is this is the change in
y
delta y that's just another way of
saying change in y
and this is
the change in x right
delta x and we figured out that the
slope
is defined really as
change in y
divided by
change in x
change in
x and another way of saying that is
delta that's that triangle delta y
divided by delta x
very straightforward
now what happens though
if we're not dealing with a straight
line let me see if i have space to draw
that
another coordinate axis
still pretty messy but i think you'll
get the point
and let's say instead of just a regular
line like this you know this follows the
standard y equals mx plus b let's just
say i had
the curve y equals x squared let me draw
it in
different color so y equals x squared
looks something like this
it's a curve you're probably pretty
familiar with it by now
and what i'm going to ask you is what is
the slope of this curve
and and think about that what does it
mean to take the slope of a curve now
well in this line the slope was the same
throughout the whole line
but if you look at this curve doesn't
the slope change right here it's almost
flat and it gets deeper steeper steeper
steeper steeper until it gets pretty
steep and if you go really far it gets
extremely steep so you're probably
saying well how do you figure out the
slope of a curve whose slope keeps
changing
well there is no slope for the entire
curve for a line there is a slope for
the entire line right because the slope
never changes but what we could try to
do is figure out what the slope is at a
given point
and the slope at a given point would be
the same as a slope of a tangent line
for example
let me pick a say green
the slope at this point
right here
would be the same as this as a slope of
my pen
would be the same as the slope
of this line right
because this line is tangent to it so it
just touches that curve and at that
exact point they would the this blue
curve y equals x squared would have the
same slope as this green line but if we
go say to a point back here even though
this is a really badly drawn
graph
the slope would be something like this
right the tangent slope the slope would
be a negative slope and here it's a
positive slope and if we took a point
here
if we took a point here the slope would
be even more positive right
so how are we going to figure this out
how are we going to figure out what the
slope is at any point along a curve like
y equals x squared
well that's where the derivative comes
in use and and now for the first time
you'll actually see why a limit is
actually a useful concept
so let me try to redraw the curve
okay i'll draw my axes
see
what's the y-axis i'll just do it in the
pi in the first quadrant
and this is
i really have to find a better tool to
do my uh
this is
x coordinate
and then let me draw my curve in yellow
so y equals x squared looks something
like this
i'm really concentrating to draw this at
least decently good
okay
so let's say we want to find
the slope at this point
at this point
let's call this
point let's call this point a
right at this point x equals a
and of course this is
this is f of a
right
it's f of a
so we could try to do is we could try to
find the slope of a secant line the the
a line between
we take another point say some somewhat
close to this point on the graph let's
say
here
and if we could figure out the slope of
this line it would be a bit of an
approximation right of the slope of
the curve exactly this point so let me
draw
that secant line so
let me
something like that secant line looks
something like that and let's say that
this point right here
is a
plus
h
right where this distance is just h
this is so a plus h we're just going h
away from a
and then this point right here
is f of
a plus h
my pen is malfunctioning
f of
a plus h
so this would be an approximation for
what the slope is at this point and the
closer that h gets the closer this point
gets to this point the better our
approximation is going to be all the way
to the point that
if we actually get the slope where h
equals 0 that would actually be the
slope the instantaneous slope at that
point in the curve but how can we figure
out what the slope is at when when h
equals 0 right because
let me let me
see so right now we're saying that the
slope between these two points it would
be
the change in y so what's the change in
y it's this
this one so this point right here is
the x coordinate is
my thing is keep messing up the x
coordinate is
is a plus h
a plus h and the y coordinate is f of a
plus h right
f of a plus h
and this point right here the coordinate
is a
and f of a
right
so if we just use the standard slope
formula like before we would say change
in y over change in x well what's the
change in y
it's f
of a plus h
right this y coordinate minus this chord
coordinate
minus
f
of a
over
the change in x well that change in x is
this x coordinate
a plus h
minus this x coordinate minus a
and of course this a and this a cancel
out so it's f of a plus h minus f of a
all over h this is just a slope of this
secant line right
and if we want to get the slope of the
tangent line we would just have to find
what happens as h gets smaller and
smaller and smaller and i think you know
where i'm going
really we just want to if we want to
find the slope of this tangent line we
just have to find the limit of this
value
the limit
of this value
as h
approaches
zero
and then if as h approaches zero this
secant line is going to get closer and
closer to the slope of the tangent line
and then we'll know the exact slope
at that instantaneous point along the
curve and actually turns out that this
is the definition of the derivative
and the derivative is nothing more than
the slope
of a curve at an exact point and this is
super useful because for the first time
you know everything we've talked about
to this point is the slope of a line but
now we can take any continuous curve
or most continuous curves and find the
slope of that curve at an exact point so
now that i've given you the definition
of what a derivative is and maybe
hopefully a little bit of intuition in
the next presentation i'm going to use
this definition to actually apply it to
some functions like x squared and others
and give you some more
problems i'll see you in the next
presentation